so it's important to find out more about
Robert Maxwell because he himself was a
very very interesting character what do
we know about Robert Maxwell oh man well
I mean we could fill up the whole
podcast
thing about Robert Maxwell to be honest
but really his intelligence connections
are a matter of record
um he was uh very closely associated
with Israeli intelligence he was also
closely associated with figures and a
Soviet and Eastern European intelligence
to a significant degree
um an alleged relationship with British
intelligence I mean it seems like he
could have been a double or triple agent
um you know very involved with
intelligent stuff and that's why it's
complicated when we talk about
intelligence affiliations oh you know
people are like um you know Robert
Maxwell was just Mossad well you know
it's more complicated than that these
people are interested in money and power
for themselves a lot of times so if it
means you know you know helping these
guys out and helping these guys out
having your hands in as many pies as
possible to rake in more money for you
and stuff like that I mean a lot of
these guys seem to do that